cast a kid who was a kid we were going
to put him in this world with all these
gods and grown-ups and he needed to be
really different than that it's a
legendary role and far from easy to book
how many auditions did you have eight
whether they were too handsome too young
or just not ready these 20 actors missed
out on the role of a lifetime who were
they there are some pretty stellar
performers ahead you'll never believe
which oscar award winner actually turned
down the gig number one we almost had
the king himself timothy chalamet is one
of the busiest actors around yes
performing an incredible range of roles
so it's no surprise that when marvel and
sony were looking for their new spidey
chalamet was a solid contender even if
the actor wasn't so confident i read
twice and i left sweating in a total
panic the actor did make the short list
but it just wasn't meant to be though
tom holland has had some words to say
about what the future might hold i think
it'd be good to bring him in as an fos
and then he kind of becomes bad
holland and chalamet in one movie sign
us up he'd be a good villain yeah
number two
from one star to another the sex
education actor got very far in the
process even getting to do a screen test
with robert downey jr but life took him
on another path
and so in the case of spider-man uh
i did sex ed because i i wouldn't have
been able to do both of those at the
same time losing out on a part like this
can be tough but butterfield was able to
take a look at the bigger picture tom
did an amazing things with peter and he
had an entirely different kind of
portrayal of him and i think it worked
so well in the universe and uh
and in in that part and i don't think i
could do it number three before 13
reasons why he could have been
spider-man dylan minnett's career hasn't
suffered from not getting that gig by
any means and he's been able to come to
terms with why it didn't work out to be
honest it was a time where i wasn't
necessarily like seeking it out really
acting professionally so young comes
with its pressures too i feel like i
wasn't at a point in my career in my
life where i could feel like i was fully
ready to commit to something like that
anyway so i don't think i gave it my all
or my best at the end of the day minette
stands holland as much as we do i think
tom holland would have always gotten the
part he was meant to be that part he's
the best spider-man i think number four
another londoner sounds good charlie
rowe and tom holland are around the same
age both auditioned to play peter parker
and they were the only two who actually
got to the point of getting two separate
screen tests with rdj of course it
wasn't fun to find out he didn't get the
part but he took the news in stride and
let the world know with a tweet well
done at tom holland 1996 glad that tom's
a mate pleased for him i thought i could
have made quite a good spider-man
number five we almost got a canadian
spider-man the up-and-coming actor has
been working steadily and made it to the
shortlist when the hunt for spider-man
was on kind of a big deal while it
didn't pan out his career has not slowed
down and we have no doubt we'll be
seeing a lot more of this skilled actor
number six it's not every day an actual
teenager auditions to play a teenager
judah lewis was only 14 years old when
he auditioned making him the perfect age
to be peter parker but not quite the
right age to play a marvel superhero
being so young just the chance to be in
the room was exciting just another step
in the journey number seven say hello to
the youngest person to audition to play
spider-man technically matt lintz was
the absolute youngest to audition for
the coveted role being born just one day
later than judah lewis he was one of the
final actors in the running but like
lewis he wasn't ready to play the role
of that age but his mcu dreams didn't go
away he wasn't spider-man but he was the
perfect person to play bruno corelli in
the disney plus series miss marvel
number eight two stabs at playing
spider-man but no dice in this case
logan lerman was one of the first actors
considered when mark webb was set to
direct the first amazing spider-man and
the fans were living for it in the end
the negotiations didn't really work out
this rejection was one the actor had to
deal with more than once though when
sony and marvel teamed up to reboot the
character lehrman was tossed into the
mix as an option but by that point he
was older than the team and wanted to
cast so close and yet so far now this we
would love to see acting from an early
age there was no question josh
hutcherson had the chops needed to play
the part and the actor was definitely at
a point in his career or he was ready to
move into the big leagues and with what
better part it's just an honor it's
really cool to be considered for that
his screen test shows a pretty
incredible performance backed with a
load of passion for the franchise i grew
up watching the originals the originals
you know the ones with tobey maguire
they came out when i was 10 years old
however this peter wasn't the right fit
but
peta
that's another story number ten who's
that just a star on the rise alden
wasn't really known when he began his
spidey audition process but that didn't
mean he wasn't ready the actor got to
meet with mark webb and he was brought
into audition for the amazing spider-man
2 as well except to play harry osborn
instead while neither worked out his
career definitely started looking up
when he booked playing han solo number
11. wait isn't that pietro he is now but
before avengers age of ultron came
around aaron taylor johnson was a
popular pick to play peter parker in the
amazing spider-man he made the short
list but once andrew garfield got the
part the actor moved on with other
projects like godzilla it wasn't the end
of his superhero dreams though since he
did of course join the mcu and made his
mark as quicksilver number 12 tom riddle
turned peter parker we're intrigued
frank delane was seriously considered
getting a meeting with mark webb and all
to discuss the possibility of working
together delane is a great actor and
getting a meeting is awesome but it just
wasn't the part ultimately he wasn't the
right fit
number 13. billy elliot is that you
jamie bell became a star playing billy
elliot in the movie in 2000 and just
like another billy elliot hey tom he
gave an amazing audition and got to the
screen test phase coming extremely close
to nabbing that job not every billy can
become a peter though but we have no
doubt belle probably would have slayed
those stunts number 14 and hello harry
osborn sam raimi and james franco were
pretty tight so franco felt hopeful
going into his peter parker screen test
and the call he got afterwards
well it wasn't really the one he was
hoping for raymie was able to soften the
blow though by giving the actor a
straight offer to play the harry osborn
it definitely worked out since he got to
perform such an iconic role especially
for the third film when he took center
stage
number 15 he was ready to save the day
the truth of the matters is in the end
he's
he's spider-man toby mcguire had already
secured his role as spider-man but after
suffering an injury while filming
seabiscuit there was a chance a new
actor would need to step in and jake
gyllenhaal started training the actor
was just waiting for the go to dive into
the spider-man sequel but the og managed
to make it back a loss for sure but
instead of replacing another actor
gyllenhaal got to bring his own
character to mysterio and tom holland
spider-man and thank goodness because
what would these bros do without each
other i was up against another actor
there was something that happened that
possibly could have happened that didn't
happen but maybe it would have you know
number 16 sometimes you just know a role
isn't for you heath ledger's agent steve
alexander reported he was the number one
choice to play spider-man in the first
sam raimi film but knowing it was such a
huge franchise and not having much of a
personal history with it ledger believed
that if he played the part he'd be
taking somebody else's dream away that's
a pretty good reason to reject a part
even if it is spider-man number 17 from
titanic to the streets of new york leo
was ready for anything shortlisted to
take on the superhero in sam raimi's
movie liu was oh so close but what did
it in the end his wildly handsome good
looks there were no hard feelings though
since the actor did get to celebrate one
of his best friends getting the gig
number 18 winning awards getting lots of
amazing offers wes bentley is no
stranger after doing american beauty wes
bentley was on a roll but he didn't want
to get ahead of himself i didn't want to
go there because i believed what i did
in american beauty was special and i had
higher expectations for myself to do
something like that again bentley passed
on pursuing the part even though it hurt
i regret not doing them and they're
painful to watch sometimes but they're a
reminder of my struggle
if i were to get those opportunities
again i'd know exactly how to handle
them number 19 what did you do last
summer he didn't spend it playing
spider-man but that doesn't mean he
didn't come awfully close when sam raimi
was getting his team together the actor
did a screen test and sony was a fan but
eventually those conversations faded and
by that point raymie knew he wanted toby
for the role number 20. last but
definitely not least sam raimi needed a
spider-man and scott speedman was a
solid contender and with his being so
popular at the time the fans were living
for it he missed out on this franchise
but it made him totally available for
his role in the underworld films instead
so many great actors to consider but in
the end we've loved getting to see the
portrayal of the beloved character from
some amazing performers especially when
they're all together who would you have
liked to see play spider-man